[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: I think a lot
about the psychology of spaces,
the intention of
architecture, the capacity
to design dwellings that
inform our inner world.
You walk into a room, and
you start feeling better,
and you don't quite know why.
Then you realize the
lighting, the shapes,
the lines, the shadows,
everything about how we've
installed, impregnated, mind
and intention and agency
into the physical form, shows us
the ways in which architecture,
in which design, is really about
the design of the inner spaces.
When you design the "without,"
you design the "within."
And this is a wonderful idea.
I think architects
don't get celebrated
enough in our society, because
these are the people that
allow us to design cities,
spaces, and dwellings
in which we unfold.
And if anything, architects
should work together
with psychologists
and with designers
who understand the impact of
shapes, shadows, and forms
upon human subjectivity.
Design matters.
Architecture matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]